telling you man you get that Malcolm
Gladwell [ __ ] 10
000 hours true
[Music]
I'm Shane Gillis I'm Dan Soder and This
Is Us answering the internet
Shane if you had to choose one cartoon
animal to have sex with who would it be
well obviously old Lola Bunny that's the
easy one that's the easy one a lot of
people go with that damn those titties
were big
forgot about Jasmine
that's a human
yeah
and we're done [ __ ] God damn it uh this
is not the month to say that ass why
Asian don't hate Asian no it's not those
types of Asians yeah uh cartoon animal
what cartoon animal there's a fox
there's a fox in like a oh the Robin
Hood yeah Mary Magdalene no no not that
one there's like a new card I don't know
I don't watch cartoons
Bible
[Music]
I was amazing
dude yeah
well I think the girl was also yeah
all the animals in zootopia I would
[ __ ]
finishing them oh yeah I just got into
that dude I'll say it right now I'm
[ __ ] normal
in front of Garfield
[Laughter]
I don't know normal the hottest piece of
ass Jim Davis ever Drew no
he's trying to think of him I'm doing a
lot of Garfield references today
I'd [ __ ] the rabbits from Watership Down
[Laughter]
yeah dude I would [ __ ] oh yes I want to
[ __ ] rabbits
water ship down check it out awesome
dark Minnie Mouse
Minnie Mouse could get it should catch
it that's fair would you rather be bald
by age 20 or 5'3 with a full head of
hair but I'm going to be bald shortly
yeah I'm I'm guessing by mid 40s 50 I'll
be bald so I'll do bald
oh you're coming don't you dare dude no
I don't care I'm going boss
your early 20s when you're young dude
just be bought just be bald and people
care about hair
too much pretty gay if you're a dude
worried about your hair congratulations
I got a weird head you can care a little
you don't care too much yeah you got big
dome though that thing goes bald it's
gonna be [ __ ] it wrong look at his head
dude it's a size eight are you yeah
[Laughter]
hold on put your hands there and let me
move my head
there's a reason my mom hates me
tore in half I [ __ ] in the end baby
ew I came out of that like that lady and
[ __ ] Siege out of that cake
if every time you got a boner the same
song would start playing what song would
you want
you go first let's hear it for the boys
let's give the boys a chance
I go yeah he's too quick uh I go I like
cashier I've been on a cashier kick oh
okay it's going down or you're gonna die
young yeah
you're gonna die yeah yeah oh I
am here to promote Kesha's old stuff
[Laughter]
Just Lose Yourself you have one shot
because then I'm not getting a bonus for
the rest of the night yeah I don't have
it like yeah
oh dude what this is great what movie
most recently made you cry Moneyball
easy what a performance what a
performance Brad Pitt what a performance
how can you not be romantic about the
game would you rather a sit on a cake
and eat a dick
sit on a dick and eat a cake I've done
this one what would you do have anal sex
with a guy and eat cake you gotta take
it in the case dude
you're suck it it's something more
masculine about getting [ __ ] in the
ass yeah we're just like oh yeah oh did
you do this Frost
no [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you're gonna finish
aren't you yeah oh you're gonna [ __ ] it
up oh we both standing up
you need something to latch onto dude
would you rather be an awesome NFL
kicker or an average NFL tight end
average NFL tight end no way man
definitely then you could play for years
as a kicker you could play for 15 years
and also you could you have that cool
post kick look where you go
as it goes through yeah I don't like I
would probably do a clamp I don't want
to do a cool thing where I'd be like
every time I hit a field goal I thought
there it is that's app ad it's good and
Dancer does your double guns
I'd be an [ __ ] kicker [ __ ] out of you
no you can think about being an [ __ ]
back up tight end
how awesome
um who is the Russian drug dude for the
Raiders Sebastian Sebastian that's
actually let me stop you there that's
actually my confirmation name it's
Sebastian because of Sebastian janakow
yes my name is Shane Michael Sebastian
Gillis because of Sebastian he's always
incredible top 10. no that was my choice
I was in eighth grade and I was like
this would be funny wasn't your first
round draft pick uh I think the Oakland
yeah they took him early and he was dude
I think I'm about to get you a Florida
FSU
Janikowski pretty tight how many that's
another Fat legend that just dude
confidence fat dude
yeah he was the John Daly of the NFL
yeah he was just ripping butts on the
sideline he's like what is it we don't
too
remember remember the Raiders line them
up from like the logo yeah
would you rather be LeBron James or Tom
Brady LeBron James I would be Tom Brady
you know why
you want to know why
say I'm just joking dude
I can't uh one of them supports Trump
one of them supports China who do you
think I'm choosing whoa yo whoa dude did
you see where there's [ __ ] horse but
yeah hey got you dude you ever [ __ ] with
me so you got quick answers
I'll just say Tom Brady stop grabbing my
balls no Tom Brady I don't know I mean
it'd be so good 6.9 and just be able to
[ __ ] rain down [ __ ] you go to a team
and you make that I don't know but
LeBron has all that pressure now of
being like he has to be like a civil
rights leader yeah that's right Tom
Brady just goes on boats and get throws
the Super Bowl trophies like I don't
give a [ __ ] everyone's like yeah Tom
Brady's like uh also football is so much
cooler than basketball but the damage
I think the damage on LeBron is probably
getting close yeah dude
all right if money didn't matter would
you rather be the first pick in the
draft and have to rebuild a shitty team
or the last pick in the first round and
instantly have a good team I mean that's
easy I'll be the first pick in the first
round and come in and just
[ __ ] [ __ ] up
instantly have a good team oh you're
saying so you got to be a late pick yeah
I'd rather be the last one okay I'd
rather be the last pick come in and just
start winning because then you got you
have that motivation that like Aaron
Rodgers and Tom Brady have or they're
like you didn't think I was [ __ ] [ __ ]
you whereas if you get to pick it and
you have to rebuild the shitty team that
is that pressure yeah it's a cool
yeah it's a cool pressure it is a cool
pressure but if you don't pull it off
your [ __ ] Manziel
I don't know about that party he was in
exactly Mandel ruled
would you rather have your balls
permanently stuck to your leg or
permanent swamp ass
I got both
what the [ __ ] are we talking are not
hard for me yeah I don't know do you
want it to be Monday or Tuesday
you know what I used to do speaking of
LeBron when I worked at a restaurant
when I was when it was cast a season
yeah in New York it was really hot
you're wearing your All Blacks you used
to have real bad yeah you're murdered
out yeah you'd murdered out I'm doing it
for someone's funeral all black you're
missing my homie but I would uh I'm
Johnny Cash
but I would take corn starch from the
kitchen and shove it up your ass and
wipe it on my butt and then LeBron
really swear to God I put cornstarch on
your ass at work good waiters back me up
waiters do that dude stop swamp ass
cornstarch dude if you ain't got no
batteries yeah it's cool
to look like bringing baby powder in I'm
like hey guys cornstarchy's going to the
walk-in like
you know it's that's [ __ ] insane
Sarge up your ass at work sorry I'm a
diver sorry I'm MacGyver go buy body
powder
it's body powder season it's coming I've
been starting to [ __ ] slam it up the
Gucci
come on
but the worst is your hand yeah keeps
the powder on it and then you gotta like
put a shirt on or something like oh you
got some of your uh yeah Sac powder on
your hand looks like an old Renaissance
King
all the time I came into it was like one
summer where I had like a place in
Newport and I went into my room and I
looked at my bed and it was G-Man my
buddy who's a bigger boy like he's not
Foley
that's [ __ ] up and fully just
descriptive size
and you can just see the outline of his
cheeks with like his balls and like and
then just powder around it and I was
like dude did you put it on like a baby
yeah he's like yeah how else would
people put it on that's so funny he
rolls oh yeah all 350 pounds you get off
my bed wait hold his legs oh no and he
sprayed it
sounds honestly
that sounds so sounds great that sounds
very refreshing but you can see his
cheeks the imprint let's go when they're
when they're very fat fat cheeks look
like two triangles yeah like it just
looks like that you're gonna see fat
cheeks because it's just a straight line
I like lady bodybuilders pecs yeah when
they get when they have the tits that
sit on top
would you rather [ __ ] a chick who's
banged a thousand dudes been there or a
chick who's banged one animal
dude thousand dudes not even a question
dang's an animal I don't want to know
that I can't follow an animal true
you don't want to know that she's like
I'm sorry about I'm
this German rearranged my [ __ ] it's
always a German Shepherd always but what
if you know why they listen to commands
they are good they're hot dogs they're
good dogs
[Laughter]
thank you
like a disturbingly good job
[Laughter]
yeah
no no no it's the other it's the other
way otherwise Arch it out yeah
they grab yeah you've got a nice back oh
there it is
and you're watching your dog huh yeah
dude my dog you've been watching when
you pull her at the park she's like
she's still trying to get it she's a
lady so I could be wrong I don't know
what about this for a fan so you go down
to Tijuana
the donkey show there it is sweet
Senoritas just got murdered by a donkey
not literally but yeah the pussy's been
ripped apart by by a burrow yeah you're
sitting there you're like
yeah I can then she goes give me 15
minutes while I sit on this ice pack
all right
I could save her you go let me go you
know a thousand dudes I'm gonna grab the
Buick I'm gonna swing this around I
can't believe this worked out I can't
believe this Doggy Show worked out who
would have thought I found love who's
gonna sound crazy my friends are gonna
love you
she's good with animals
she's bilingual
a thousand dudes a thousand dudes a
thousand dicks descending upon you
tonight we suck in hell yeah it's a
tough one yeah thousand dollars I don't
know man I feel like it that one dog
everybody gets a dog yeah but I feel
like at that point she's got she's got a
throwing motion yeah you love slots dude
dude I'm sorry it's right off the
fingertips every time it's a vet she's a
wiley vet a lady with an animal I don't
know what she's gonna pick up and put in
her that could be good though no you
want a wild card around the house no I
don't I don't want her to be like hey by
the way your tennis racket you're at the
mall walking past PetSmart she's like
no she just grabs your arm you'll stop
it we're not going to the dog tracks
can I go see the horses it's a
Labradoodle
yeah what type of animal [ __ ] her sex
with an animal you could get a Richard
Gere situation that's easily fallable
fight for its life
can't drive
all right well hey there you could say
animal no I mean you gotta go with you
you got to go with a thousand dogs I'm
telling you man you get that Malcolm
Gladwell [ __ ]
ten thousand hours true
that's how you know
yeah I like I appreciate what you're
saying I agree
Jillian keeps in the bonfires go do both
you can do both of this world thank you
for watching the first episode back of
answer the internet be sure to like this
video subscribe to this channel comment
below with what comedian or celebrity
you want to see play into the internet
and go right here to buy answer the
internet the game and also download the
app for free
foreign